foreign
[Music]
legendary has just released its first
images of their upcoming Apple TV series
Monarch the legacy of monsters and boy
oh boy do we have quite a few things to
tell you we got four images as well as
some information about what the series
will be about so let's get to it
so the first picture the first image we
see is that of Godzilla roaring with a
woman in the foreground this is
definitely Godzilla from San Francisco
but whether it is when he first arrived
or after the fight against the mutors is
yet unconfirmed but but since the
picture shows a rainy day and a fight
took place during a late rainy afternoon
and evening time and also by the time
Godzilla woke again in the morning the
next day it wasn't raining anymore
therefore it would be right before his
encounter with both the male and the
female mutos in that fateful day just
after he destroys the Golden Bridge
so now the question is will we see
different angles for the 2014 meter
fight a revisit to the same event but
from different perspectives and angles
well there is a high chance we might
just cause of the movie of 2014 well it
was highly praised for its storyline and
acting as well as being Godzilla's first
time in America but rushing aside the
Abomination 1998 TriStar version yeah it
was hail 2014 was hailed as a good movie
but the only criticism was that it was
too dark and the mutos and the G-Man was
only seen in short scenes the lacking of
screen time for the monsters was the
main drawback and I'm guessing that they
will remedy it as well as adding a few
extra shots to you know Season the
legendary battle so that's that after
the battle we might likely see a time
Jump to a different point in time
whether it's somewhere before kotm or
back in the 1950s is for everyone to
find out so in a glimpse of Monarch
Legacy of Monsters the upcoming series
confirms that Kurt Russell you know the
guy the ego from goddess of the Galaxy
Vol 2 so he is collaborating with his
own son white Russell another MCU guy
that was seen in the Falcon and the
Winter Soldier and they both will work
together to depict the same character
they both will be portraying army
officer Lee Shaw with Wyatt acting as
him in the 1950s when Monarch was
beginning to be created and the Titans
were being discovered for the very first
time in modern society and then Kurt
Russell will portray the character in
the 21st century around 50 to 60 years
later this narrative will unfold as
Monarch faces a dire threat stemming
from Shaw's knowledge hidden knowledge
this will span three generations the
storyline and the gripping tale will
unveil long worried secrets and
demonstrate how Monumental world shaking
events can have far-reaching impacts on
Humanity stemming from just hidden
information and secrets
so throughout the most diverse films
Monarch's role evolves from a secretive
entity studying Titans and monsters to a
central player in Humanity's efforts to
coexist and understand these ancient
beings the organization's history its
Founders and its long-term goals are
gradually unveiled creating a sense of
continuity and World building across the
movies and this will climax in the
series the actual beginnings of murak
isn't really known but we do know that
in modern history Godzilla and shinamura
emerged in the late 1940s and then in
the 1950s the U.S military was trying to
kill the Big G with nukes in Bikini
Atoll not really knowing or realizing
that they were in fact giving sweet
radiation cakes to Godzilla as he feeds
off of radioactivity anyway it is here
in this time period that the
organization might have its roots
who knows we might also see Godzilla
fight Muto Prime and develop his docile
scales after the gruesome encounter
since the series will be delving into
the history of the Titans and their
legacy this means that the series will
most definitely cover the Aftershock
battle between the G-Man and Prime to
miss this is to miss the timeline of the
most of us as a whole this will give a
pause as well for Godzilla in the series
as he will be recuperating from the
injuries sustained in the fight
therefore this means that other Titans
will hold a limelight because in the
days between 2014 and kotm 17 motels
were discovered as stated by sharizawa
this will give way for the series to
dive into their Discovery and unraveling
what information that army officer Lee
Shaw has in his mind that is a threat to
the world
yeah lastly just like Godzilla minus one
which had a poster reveal and then a
couple of days later a short teaser we
might just get the same thing here maybe
a teaser or trailer and the official
release date in a few days time there is
the second season of invasion from
Creator Simon kinberg and David wheel
premiering globally on Wednesday August
23 on Apple TV plus so if we are lucky
we might get a trailer during that time
as well or maybe before
anyway that's about all I have to say on
this topic right now so I hope you have
enjoyed watching this video do hit the
like button for support and subscribe
but most of all smash that Bell icon for
regular updates on new videos here on
this channel take care fam